By now we are aware of almost all the changes
that occur during puberty in
both boys and girls.
So can you tell me which is the most important
of all
changes?
Yes!
It is the development of reproductive organs.
The stage of sexual maturation is what defines
puberty in true sense.
And what
do we mean by this?
This means that the individual is now physically
capable
of reproduction.
So are we saying that both males and females
are capable of reproduction with
the onset of puberty?
Absolutely!
And that would mean that they can
reproduce anytime throughout their life right?
Absolutely NOT!
Why not?
The basic reason for this is that the case
of males
and females is different when it comes to
the reproductive span.
And why is
this different?
This is what we need to answer in this video
that deals with the concept of
REPRODUCTIVE PHASE.
Now what exactly do we mean by this?
Let us understand the two words.
REPRODUCTIVE here means the process of reproduction.
And Phase means
the time period.
So are we saying that individuals are capable
of reproduction
only for some period of time?
Yes!
And this is applicable only in case of
Females.
But why so?
Let me explain.
In case of males, development of testes causes
production of gametes, that is
sperms.
And this process once started, does not terminate
throughout the
male’s life.
Only the sperms produced can decrease in count
with age.
However, the ability to reproduce still remains
the same.
But the case of females is completely different.
Females cannot reproduce
throughout their lives.
The term Reproductive phase holds true in
their case.
And why is it so?
Well the simplest answer to this question
is the process of OVULATION!
Yes!
Can you guess from the name, what is ovulation?
It is the process of release of
ova from the ovaries.
Now you may wonder how the process can be
an answer to this question.
It’s simple!
We know that reproduction requires an egg
cell as the female
gamete.
And if ovulation is the release of egg cells,
then that means
reproduction will be possible only when egg
cells are released.
But do you
know that in every female individual, the
number of egg follicles in the ovaries
is fixed?
That means the ovaries will have fixed number
of immature egg cells
stored inside them since the beginning.
However, only on the onset of puberty,
the egg cells are released one after the other.
So don’t you think the capacity of reproduction
will begin when the first egg
cell will be released by the ovary?
Yes!
And it will obviously stop when the
number of egg cells will come to an end!
This phase is nothing but the reproductive
phase in females.
The beginning and end of this important phase
are given scientific names.
The commencing point is called as MENARCHE.
So can we say a girl
experiences Menarche when she steps into puberty?
Yes!
And the occurrence
differs from one female to the other.
However the average age range to expect
Menarche is around twelve to fourteen years.
Also, the time when it
terminates is called MENOPAUSE!
This time is also different in females.
But the
average period of age is between forty five
to fifty years.
Let us just imagine that one of the ovaries
has released an egg cell.
It goes
straight to the fallopian tube and then moves
further.
Now if this egg gets
fertilised, then the foetus will need a proper
location for placental attachment
right?
For this, a proper thick cushion layer made
up of cells needs to be
formed inside the uterus.
We know this layer is called the ENDOMETRIUM.
But how will the reproductive tract know whether
fertilisation is going to occur
or not?
How will it form the Endometrium all of a
sudden if fertilisation occurs?
The natural tendency of our body is to be
prepared for every possibility!
So in
this case too, our body makes the necessary
preparations.
When the ovum is
released from either of the ovaries, many
hormones work in co-ordination to
get the endometrial layer ready.
In case fertilisation occurs, the foetus will
have a proper location for placental attachment.
Wait a second… we said if fertilisation
occurs!
What if it doesn’t?
In that case
the ovum will come out of the body through
the vagina.
And what will happen
to the endometrium?
Astonishingly, the layer also collapses and
gets out of the
body through the vagina.
As a result of this, for almost four to five
days every month, a female
experiences a bleeding phase.
The bleeding is through the vagina and it
contains the unfertilised ovum, the cells
of endometrium and blood of course!
This is called as the MENSTRUAL FLUID.
And the process is referred to as
Menstruation.
Did you notice I mentioned that the bleeding
phase is four to five days EVERY
MONTH?
Why did I say every month?
That is because the entire process occurs
in a cyclic manner that lasts for
twenty eight to thirty days.
The ovulation and building up of the endometrium,
and then followed by this will be collapsing
of endometrium in case
fertilisation does not occur.
This will give rise to the discharge of the
menstrual
fluid through the vagina.
Don’t you think this entire cycle will also
have a scientific name?
Of course!
It is
called the MENSTRUAL CYCLE.
So the Menstrual cycle is almost a twenty
eight
to thirty day cycle out of which the bleeding
phase lasts for four to five days.
In a nutshell, the reproductive ability is
obtained by individuals with the onset
of puberty.
In males, it lasts till they’re alive.
However, in females the
reproductive phase is marked by the menarche,
and concluded by menopause.
The time period in between is where the body
undergoes the menstrual cycle.
The reproductive capacity of females is only
found during this phase.
So we have talked about the process that happens
when fertilisation does not
take place.
But what if fertilisation occurs?
Do we know whether it’ll be a boy or a girl?
Let us learn about the concept of
SEX DETERMINATION in the next video!